hey everybody you've been messaging me
about the new synopsis they drop for all
the Marvel movies that are coming up so
let's breakdown thor ragnarok there's a
new round of the spider-man giveaway
going on right now - just because that's
the next movie that's coming up it's for
the action figures all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video so you probably heard
Marvel released new synopsis for all of
its movies including infinity war it
tells us a little bit about each of the
movies so I'm going to focus on Thor
Ragnarok just because that's the next
big thing coming up after spider-man
homecoming which funny enough they
didn't release any new information about
maybe that's because we've already
gotten so many trailers but here it is
so it says his devious brother Loki has
taken over Asgard the powerful hella has
emerged to steal the throne for herself
in Thor is imprisoned on the other side
of the universe to escape captivity and
save his home from imminent destruction
Thor must first win a deadly alien
contest by defeating his former ally and
fellow Avenger the Incredible Hulk
with a giant exclamation point like they
want you to scream The Incredible Hulk
just like Jeff Goldblum it says nothing
of infinity gem although there are a lot
of theories about Heimdall I'll address
that as well as how hella can be so
powerful that she can destroy Thor's
hammer which itself contains the essence
of a storm god if you haven't been
reading the Thor comic recently they
have the female version of Thor and then
the unworthy Thor which is like the
traditional Thor Odinson
she's inviting the Phoenix force they
address it a couple times they did the
origin of Thor's hammer where they
address how it is that Odin came to bind
the storm god into the hammer itself as
they were forging it it was so powerful
that Odin was not able to control the
hammer that's how powerful Thor's hammer
is the hammer itself is literally a God
but I'm not expecting the MCU to take it
quite that far but soul gem aside
there's so many reasons to explain how
she is able to do this now Helen in the
comics is the mistress of Hell she gains
her power from the souls that she calls
from Asgard she has the ability to call
a certain percentage of Asgardian souls
they literally read like the powers of
the soul gem so the things that she does
naturally just sound like what they
might tie to an infinity stone so she
does have some healthy
see a little bit of Karl Urban scourge
in here but without the soul gem there's
very little to explain how she's able to
raise Asgard to the ground in an instant
like this this looks a little bit like
the power gem this is going to be so
much fun so obviously you see Thor go up
against her she catches the hammer while
they're on earth breaks it and then
effectively just punch him across the
universe with her power like she kicks
him across the universe and this is kind
of funny they explained the reason why
it's a car that he winds up on and the
reason why it looks like a garbage dump
is because in the MCU so car is
literally at the end of all these
different space ways in the universe
where all the universes trash just gets
collected so if you saw the scene during
guardians of the galaxy when they're
bouncing around like a pinball machine
as they're jumping to ego the Living
Planet you can only jump between
galaxies using very specific jump point
Plinko style eventually all these
gateways just dump at a certain part of
the universe and that just happens to be
Sekar so the Grandmaster is ruling over
the literal trash planet and that
explains why everything's so colorful
one I mean obviously it looks really
cool and it enables them to do this
really crazy Jack Kirby style art but
isn't it funny that all of this
collected cobbled together trash armor
costumes just happened to look like a
lot of the Celestials which we learned
from guardians of the galaxy are a big
thing in the Marvel Universe thank you
very much again James Gunn
but Loki winds up on this planet because
he also gets his ass kicked out of
Asgard he's been pretending to be Odin
whatever he's been doing we've learned
that it's enabled hella to escape
imprisonment this could be a comic book
thing where she escapes Hell or it could
be an actual physical prison because in
the comics Odin just tasks her to watch
over Hell which just becomes her duty to
uphold the cosmic balance but because I
don't think they're ever going to do the
Angela character in the movies because
there's some rights issues with Neil
Gaiman but in the comics Angela totally
badass character is sort of like the
banished daughter of Asgard they might
choose to give some aspects of that
storyline too hella to give her a reason
for resenting Odin and Asgard so much
like the synopsis says that she wants
the throne of Asgard for herself but why
does she want
she could radon in salt steal all of his
powerful artifacts it sounds like she's
going to create an army for herself but
if she's wielding an Infinity stones and
what good is sitting on Asgard for her
she could go anywhere she wanted to do
whatever she wanted the reason that Loki
wants to throne is because he does have
feelings for his family he loves his
brother but there's just so much
deep-seated resentment over his own
father it's a lot of textbook daddy
issues so it makes a little more sense
that he's jealous he wants to steal his
brother's throne put his father on earth
take his memories away so that he
doesn't remember that he's Odin in one
of the most powerful people in the
universe but if he really wanted to he
could kill Odin but he doesn't because
he still cares for him Pella seems like
she does not so you can let me know in
the comments why do you think it is the
ELA wants the throne of Asgard when she
doesn't need it she just needs the
things that are at Asgard all the
artifacts in the soul gem but all that
explains how Loki ends up on Sekar but
the Grand Master is so powerful controls
the planet they can't just walk away
without Thor fighting his way through
the arena that's a bit of a flimsy
excuse for all this fighting from the
Planet Hulk storyline but it is really
cool so you want to see it anyway you're
like okay there's really no good reason
for Thor to fight Hulk other than it
being one of the most fun things later
this year and one of the reasons why I
think that Thor Ragnarok is going to
make way more money than the other
Marvel movies that are coming out this
year so know you have all kinds of
questions about what's going on with
Odin how does he come back what role
does Doctor Strange have in the movie
he's not mentioned anywhere in the
synopsis really the only reason that
he's in the movie is to help them find
Odin restore his memories because
there's an enchantment on him that sort
of separated his mind from his body so
he has no idea who he is he's just like
this crazy old man that just wandering
around on earth so why bring him here to
me war long story
families Ramah the kind of thing but
we're looking for my father okay
so if you found Bowden you'd all return
to Asgard promptly
oh yes promptly I'm going to help you
but for those of you wondering why it is
that they destroy Thor's hammer I think
it's mostly so that when we get to
infinity war they can get to ultimate
Mjolnir and he can wield the giant axe
hammer from the comics just because it
looks so much more badass unworthy
Thor's also been wielding yarby or
that's the name of his axe there's
actually a picture of it here from
behind the scenes we'll see how they get
from y'all near to ultimate Mjolnir but
they sound like they're going to have
one of the biggest action set-pieces
from any movie ever towards the end of
the film this is one of the behind the
scenes shots of them getting ready to
film part of that scene these here are a
whole bunch of the most expensive
cameras that you could possibly use to
film a movie so think about what they
would be filming with all of these
slaves together pointing in the same
direction just something that is
absolutely mind-blowing Lee huge so that
sounds like it's going to be like the
big final battle when Odin gets his
powers back goes full Odin force on all
the forces of Ragnarok hella in whatever
it is that she's able to do with the
soul gem in the comics it really just
has the ability to control soul so
you're kind of like em seeing people so
it sounds like hella takes over the
minds of a lot of these Asgardian
soldiers the movie might give it some
more visually based powers just to make
it look a little more spectacular
because Thor is all about spectacle for
those asking though I think that Thor
Ragnarok is going to earn the most money
of any of the Marvel movies there are
three this year because we have
guardians of the galaxy to spider-man
homecoming and then Thor Ragnarok I
think largely due to the presence of
Hulk Thor will earn the most money
spider-man homecoming will be right
below that because it'll be like the
first new big spider-man movie with Tom
Hall and so everyone will show up even
if it's not the greatest movie in the
history of spider-man movies and you
have Iron Man in it so there'll be a lot
of people that will just show up to see
what it looks like and then just like a
little bit below that will be guardians
of the galaxy - I don't think that any
of the movies will earn more than a
billion dollars Thor has a chance to get
really close but I don't think that any
of these Marvel movies are going to
cross
billion dollars without it being an
Avengers movie and having more Avengers
characters in it so let me know in the
comments which Marvel movie this year do
you think is going to earn the most
money and will any of them earn more
than a billion dollars so leave all your
requests for Marvel bonus videos in the
comments below I'll say congratulations
to Jason nuyen you're the latest
giveaway winner please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details while you
wait for everything to post you can
click here to learn all about Tom Hardy
becoming the venom of the spider-man
universe and you can click here for
brand new spider-man homecoming trailer
thank you so much for watching let's
high-five I'll see you guys tonight
you